ça y est j'ai enfin fini tout netflix
toute prime vidéo tout c'est rien que
pour regarder tout netflix selon une
étude il faudrait quatre années de
visionnage consécutive et je fais ça non
mais j'avoue que ces derniers mois avec
le confinement j'avais un peu que ça va
faire des maths et des séries et c'est
très addictif
je regardais plein de séries d'une
traite ouais j'ai fait de bint soit
chinois se moque line switching quand on
l'entend dire est un sport nautique
ultra extrême cet été j'ai fait que du
benchmark xingguo alors ça veut juste
dire moi les regarder la télé pendant
l'autre j'ai regardé une série qui est
sorti a longtemps sévi king gros kiff en
fait je crois que je me suis vachement
identifiés aux vikings déjà peut-être
par rapport à la signification de mon
prénom
norman est un prénom vikings sa racine
vient de l'anglais nous mêmes ou north
mhz ce qui signifie l'homme du nord
par contre moi c'est plutôt lens et
roubaix c'est le nord mais pas très très
loin il est forcément en regardant
vikings suis devenu un gros fan de
ragnarok l'acteur parce que le vrai on
dirait plus un mec en cause que
d'astérix je voulais tellement
ressembler à rhein art que je réagirais
coiffeur et j'ai demandé une coupe
vikings comment vous dire
vous voulez voir le résultat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà ouais c'est un peu raté ouais je
n'imaginais pas comme ça sinon je
n'aurais pas fait on dirait juste kevin
tuning des anges 15 ou 1 babos cracheurs
de feu là excuse-moi manne pour réparer
l'indus à des pannes ou me dit rouler ou
même une feuille d'arbre j'en ai rien à
[ __ ]
non au mieux mais bon j'ai quand même
gardé cette coupe pendant la suite de la
vidéo parce que trop tard je voulais
aussi avoir la barbe façon rouleau mais
vu que j'ai une barre de pré pubères
depuis un mois je mets tous les jours de
8 de ricin pour ça pousse mieux et ça
c'est pas trés viking's way attend deux
minutes mon masque imprègne je m'épile
lucu et j'arrive
résultat j'ai toujours pas de barbe par
contre dès que téléphone mon écran et
plein de l'huile toute la journée mais
jousson gluante
heureusement qu'on fait plus la bise
bref je me suis carrément écartés du
sujet et regarder des kings ça tue parmi
les programmes qui sont devenus cultes
ces derniers mois tiger king en france
et au royaume des fauves à moi bah moi
c'est un gradé tiger king en premier dit
que ces sorties away génial attend qu'on
m'appelle c'est netflix
ils veulent pas envoyer une médaille
quelle couleur tu veux bleu rouge sans
spoil est ailleurs king c'est une série
documentaire qui raconte l'histoire de
différents gérants de zoo à grand félin
aux états unis dit comme ça ça paraît
pas ouf
mais c'est une dinguerie rien que lui il
suffit c'est une sorte de redneck
manipulateur narcissique polygame à
ryadh mais qu'en même temps à la fois
dresseur de tigres magicien star du net
chanteur candidat aux élections
présidentielles américaines qui veut
flinguer tout le monde avec son revolver
de cow boy hey joe exotique il est
tellement barré et si on avait mis dans
une fiction je suis sûr que les gens
auraient dit non mais ce personnage
n'est pas du tout crédible c1 c'est
ridicule à ce que nous aimons n'y crois
pas je sais pas quel scénariste a écrit
cela mais c'est juste à chypre toujours
sans date fixe
impossible d'être passé à côté de toi
aussi tu es qui me disait qui n'est déjà
pas du tout une série 1 c'est un film
mais je le glisse quand même c'est un
drame qui raconte l'histoire d'un père
déficient mental alors déjà comme les
français arrivent pas à prononcer le
titre non plus on l'appelle le film turc
et je trouve ça grave réducteur en fait
comme si les turcs avait seulement fait
de leur vie
un seul film à écouter certains
voudraient qu'ils ont inventée que ce
film et les toilettes turques et le gros
délire des gens c'est de se filmer en
train de pleurer en regardant ce film
[ __ ] on se faisait vraiment chez
pendant confinement je me moque parce
qu'ils me suis pareil très émotif dès
que je regarde un truc parfois turbines
ge est une série pendant des mois et
tous les jours tu vois les mêmes bears
j'en fait limite tu les vois plus que ta
propre famille tu as souvent un
personnage préféré avec qui tu nous lis
presque des liens quoi et un jour les
scénaristes décide de le tuer comme ça
sans prévenir
et là tu te sens mieux affecté au plus
haut point quoi j'ai perdu quelqu'un qui
était pour moi très important
c'est parti trop tôt la saison 4 dont
j'aimerais qu'on fasse toi et moi une
minute de silence en l'honneur de sa
mémoire
je
j'ai pas mal bendjé prime vidéo et j'ai
vu que prime vidéo ils ont atteint le
même nombre d'abonnés que netflix alors
que à la base c'est même pas leur métier
initial de faire ça ils sont très très
forts patron vient d'atteindre le même
nombre d'abonnés que netflix sur amazon
video on a une plateforme vidéo nous
chez ba c'est génial faut que je
m'abonne merci pour l'info nadine tu
peux me transférer 1 milliard je vais
acheter à une claque maintenant il ya
tellement de plateforme vidéo apple tv +
disney plus les prendre tout c'est
beaucoup trop cher et une seule c'est
frustrant et en prendre aucune bas c'est
frustrant aussi moi quand je paye une
plateforme vidéo que j'utilise jamais
été et fois je vais dessus en forçant à
chercher une série pour rentabiliser mon
abonnement après moi je suis un énorme
radin heureusement qu'il existe les
plateformes de streaming disent non le
confinement sort était vraiment ben moi
je viens de bin djaouad chez les amours
et là je vais faire la saison 4 de
questions pour un champion mecs ça fait
juste énorme
huawei j'ai regardé beaucoup de séries
que ma copine mais c'est assez compliqué
disons que il ya une catégorie de gens
qui existe qui devant une série pas
pourquoi deviennent intransigeant sur la
concentration
les fans bon je te plaît tu ne range pas
recruter un dernier message
voilà c'est bon bon ça suffit maintenant
comme c'est bon j'ai un cerveau
multifonctions quoi mais moi je fais
suivre adopta tu sais suis moi je sais
pas sur ses terres de chaux dans le
temps je suis maintenant stopper
parfois quand tu sais plus quoi regarder
tu demande de l'aide à tes potes il ya
toujours un mec plein de bonne volonté
qui se lance ok mais qu est ce que tu as
déjà vu
france si j'en suis au stade de demander
aux gens c'est que j'ai déjà vu tous les
classiques c'est trop cool de découvrir
une vieille série je trouve une bonne
série ça reste une bonne série toi c'est
comme un bon vin twin peaks ça fait 30
ans que ces cultes mais c'est vrai que
si tu regardes une série qui date à mort
tu veux un peu en parler les gens sont
un peu moins fond dedans regardez un peu
en ce moment supercopter non
[Musique]
en vrai ya tellement de série de films
de docuware garder ses enfants
stephen hawking disait que ouais j'ai lu
stephen hawking lucien humains se
mettaient à lire tous les livres de la
terre non-stop sans interruption une
seule ville suffirait pas pour lire tous
les livres
voilà donc pour la sélection des livres
mais c'est pareil pour les séries et
pour les films tchao
si vous avez une série ou un programme à
me conseiller des clients commentaire
ça m'intéresse vraiment parce que
clairement je suis là je suis en manque
abonnez vous à ma chaîne youtube en
cliquant ou en appuyant ici et n'oubliez
pas d'activer la petite cloche toi même
tu connais la fonction très pratique
allez ciao
[Musique]